over the weekend there's a breaking news
story
russia is calling for peace in ukraine
now this is great news right wow
russia is gonna they invaded the country
so it's kind of up to russia if the war
is over and
putin came out and he said there's gonna
be peace wow what great news except i
didn't believe it when i saw it i don't
really believe any news coming out of
ukraine whether it's on the ukrainian
side or whether it's on the russian side
we are in the fog of war there is an
insane amount of propaganda coming out
of that conflict russia
infamously is one of the greatest
polities for propaganda in the history
of the world i mean the soviets
perfected the art of propaganda and the
west we in the west are not so bad at it
either so i said i just don't believe it
but take a listen if you're watching
right now take a look
at this video of putin declaring peace
i don't speak russian but i can read the
transcript and the transcript says we've
managed to reach peace with ukraine
and he announces the restoration of the
independence of crimea as a republic
within ukraine so he's not not only in
this clip is he saying ukraine gets to
remain a country but he's saying
actually crimea which we took eight
years ago now we're going to give that
back as a independent republic within
ukraine wow i know this isn't true i
know this would never happen in a
million years but i'm seeing it happen
with my very eyes well you know what
this is i think i've kind of
hinted at it enough it's a deep fake
but it's a really deep fake so it sounds
like him
it looks like him
the audio syncs up with the mouth
movements
i actually can't believe my lying eyes
forget about we talked about the all the
kind of propaganda coming out of the war
on the ukrainian side we hear about the
ghost of kiev and they've got video of
the airplane this ace fighter jet
shooting down the russians and it was
from a video game it wasn't real and
you're seeing a lot of this from the
russian side too you're seeing lots of
claims being made
about
one of the claims was
from the
true fact that ukraine has bio labs that
are funded by the us and run in
collaboration with the us they said that
they had developed an ethnically
targeted bio weapon you know a bio
weapon that just zeros i guess it just
zeroes in on the russians but not other
people that seemed a little far fetched
because you're seeing a lot of this
propaganda come out
but now you got this even a video of
poot you can't even believe
that
there's a real breakdown of trust here
[Music]
you